[Music]
take a look at the water in this glass
refreshing hydrating and invaluable to
your survival before you take a sip
though how do you know that the water
inside is free from disease-causing
organisms and pollutants one out of ten
people in the world can't actually be
sure that their water is clean and safe
to drink why is that inadequate
sanitation poor protection of drinking
water sources and improper hygiene often
lead to sewage and feces contaminated
water that's the ideal breeding ground
for dangerous bacteria viruses and
parasites and the effects of these
pathogens are staggering diarrheal
disease from unsafe water is one of the
leading causes of death around the world
for children under five and according to
a UN report from 2010 microbial
waterborne illnesses killed more people
per year than war proper treatment
processes though can address these
threats they usually have three parts
sedimentation filtration and
disinfection once water has been
collected in a treatment facility it's
ready for cleaning the first step
sedimentation just takes time the water
sits undisturbed allowing heavier
particles to sink to the bottom often
though particles are just too small to
be removed by sedimentation alone and
need to be filtered gravity pulls the
water downward through layers of sand
that catch leftover particles in their
pores prepping the water for its final
treatment a dose of disinfectant
chemicals primarily forms of chlorine
and ozone are mixed in to kill off any
pathogens and to disinfect pipes and
storage systems chlorine is highly
effective in destroying waters living
organisms but its use remains government
regulated because it has potentially
harmful chemical byproducts and if an
imbalance of chlorine occurs during the
disinfection process it can trigger
other chemical reactions
for example levels of chlorine
byproducts like trihalomethanes could
skyrocket leading to pipe corrosion and
the release of iron copper and lead into
drinking water water contamination from
these and other sources including
leaching chemical spills and run offs
has been linked to long-term health
effects like cancer cardiovascular and
neurological diseases and miscarriage
unfortunately analyzing the exact risks
of chemically contaminated water is
difficult so while it's clear that
disinfectants make us safer by removing
disease-causing pathogens experts have
yet to determine the full scope of how
the chemical cocktail in our drinking
water really impacts human health so how
can you tell whether the water you have
access to whether from a tap or
otherwise is drinkable firstly too much
turbidity trace organic compounds or
high-density heavy metals like arsenic
chromium or lead mean that the water is
unsuitable for consumption a lot of
contaminants like lead or arsenic won't
be obvious without tests but some clues
like cloudiness brown or yellow
coloration a foul odor or an excessive
chlorine smell can indicate the need to
investigate further water testing kits
can go a step further and confirm the
presence of many different contaminants
and chemicals with many types of
contamination
there are ways of treating water where
it's used instead of close to its source
point of use treatment has actually been
around for thousands of years ancient
Egyptians boiled away many organic
contaminants with the sun's heat and in
ancient Greece Hippocrates designed a
bag that trapped bad tasting sediments
from water today point-of-use processes
usually involve ionization to lower
mineral content they also use adsorption
filtration where a porous material
called activated carbon strains the
water to remove contaminants and
chemical byproducts
while it's not always an effective
long-term solution point of views
treatment is portable easy to install
and adaptable and in regions where
large-scale systems are unavailable or
where water has been contaminated
further along its journey these systems
can mean the difference between life and
death clean water remains a precious and
often scarce commodity there are nearly
800 million of us who still don't have
regular access to it the good news is
that continued developments in water
treatment both on a large and small
scale can alleviate a lot of unsafe
conditions implementing proper systems
where they're needed and paying careful
attention to the ones already in place
will fulfill one of the most basic of
our human needs
[Music]
you